let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
so welcome to the tony michaels podcast
episode two
episode two thanks for joining us
on inauguration day it's kind of crazy
that
last week on episode one we were
on impeachment day and episode 2 we're
here on
inauguration day and i want to bring
in sam
oh let's see if that'll work there we go
there's sam
oh maybe sorry technical difficulties
hi hey sam there she is
what's up sam's doing mom things again
today
every wednesday so what did you think so
what did you think of the inauguration
you said you watched some of it
so i got to listen to most of it since i
was in the car
i'm always in the car and i really
enjoyed
what i heard it's it was encouraging
um there was a pastor that prayed i was
very encouraged by that i know you were
too
i was so much i bet
and my atheist it was smooth
it was very sad that there wasn't there
wasn't
um like there weren't citizens there
because of the pandemic
so we didn't get to have like a big
audience
yeah so that was one of the things that
i think
uh was very strange the imagery was very
strange
um in that there wasn't as many people
there
it was very weird to see like all the
politicians and all the people sitting
really far apart
they weren't sitting right next to each
other right
it's very very awkward very odd but um
they got through it uh the other thing
obviously the imagery of like
the fences and the barbed wire around
the
around the capitol and around dc was uh
kind of weird
but you didn't see a lot of that on the
tv they didn't show a lot of that uh
on the tv right next to the capitol but
yeah what did you
think did you think of uh joe biden's
speech uh he said that
he hopes that he can govern he hopes
that he governs
the people as well that the people that
voted against him
as well as the people that voted for him
and i kind of hope he lives up to his
word
that's i mean you caught the
you caught the message of unity then
inside of your speech
i did okay that's that's good that's
good i i think uh i think he's genuine
in that guard
um i think a lot of people get the the
word unity and what unity means
uh confused you know we've talked about
january 6th and what happened january 6
and i'm gonna play a clip later
uh of a tick tock that i did about j6
before or january 6th uh we're going to
play that clip a little later to do it i
told you so moment
but uh you know as as embarrassing as
january 6 was for this country
uh and you used that word earlier
embarrassing uh
you know i i think the unity is not with
the people who storm the capital i think
the unity is against the idea of why
they storm the capital that this is not
a this is not an okay thing
so i think that message is there i think
it's good i think he's genuine about it
i don't think you know like i told you
earlier i don't think joe biden really
uh has any reason to to inflate his ego
this guy was vice president for eight
years
so it's not like joe biden has all this
all this stuff to prove he can handle
uh national politics i mean this guy was
the vice president for eight years
so i think that's important he's seen
something he knows the things
so what did you what did being being a
female
being a woman what did you think of the
first woman being inaugurated
as vice president how does that what is
that because i'm a dude so
and i'm a white dude so all the
presidents besides barack obama have
looked like
on behalf of my whole gender it's pretty
badass
it is very it's it's eye-opening it's
heartwarming it is badass
it's pretty [ __ ] sweet because i
truly believe that like
our way out of this our way out of this
and what i mean by like
this whole equality you know uh this
this moment in history that we're at
we're trying to figure out who the [ __ ]
we are again
i think the whole way out of it is to
let women run this [ __ ]
full stop let them have the [ __ ]
no i'm serious just like okay we're
gonna put a
bunch of [ __ ] moms in charge and this
[ __ ] is gonna get cleaned the [ __ ]
up we are we are sick and tired
yes men have [ __ ] this up long enough
enough of this [ __ ] where white
white males still [ __ ] this up we need
to
we need to put women in charge mom's in
charge
and speaking speaking of women uh we had
talked about
the uh amanda gorman's speech
um that she is [ __ ] amazing
it was very encouraging to that
that speech not only can she write a
[ __ ] speech
but holy [ __ ] can she deliver a speech
i mean anyone anyone who anyone who
public speaks
or talks into a microphone she should be
[ __ ] jealous
of how good she is she was we that's not
the last one
amanda gorman so everybody has to come
up with a pedestal
i i completely agree i mean i like joe
biden's speech it was a really good
inauguration speech i thought it was
a little long uh i didn't think he had
to go quite that long to say what he
said
um you know i'll be critical of joe
biden when i think i need to be
and i think his speech was a little long
it was it was right on point he had the
good message
in there but man did he ass kicked by
her
holy [ __ ] uh uh she was she was the
highlight and that's
i did my tick tock on her today because
i was so freaking impressed
um by her i thought it was i thought it
was an awesome moment
and it really it really shows because
you know the the
kamala harris the vice president she's
not only a black
woman but she's also an indian woman
and obviously she's the first female
vice president
and she's the first black vice president
which is
also awesome but here follows up this
young strong black woman gets up there
and she just lays it all out on the line
maybe it's such a great message in the
coming year
you know i mean i don't know she runs
for politics but we definitely this is
not the last time we've heard
heard from uh uh young miss gorman for
sure
she is she is going to uh make some
history somehow rather in her writing or
in her speeches
she's definitely going to make some
history so
so you asked me a question
earlier and i guess that's maybe where
we should start here too
is your question that you asked me uh
you can go ahead and ask me again
so of all all the things
that all mr trump has done everything
for the past four years has he done
anything
good in your eyes so
it's been a long [ __ ] four
years long
long long
[ __ ] four years
but i do believe
that the the the shining light through
the absolute dumpster fire
that this guy set off in this country is
that he he made it easy for us to spot
the worst of the worst of us
um as much as that really stoked the
fire
america really needed to wake up to the
fact that we have not we have not
dealt with white grievance and equality
yet we have not done that we have not
dealt with white supremacy in this
country we have not dealt with all kinds
of issues
in this country and nothing
nothing showed that more than after
december 14th
i think that point from december 14th
when the electoral college
uh was was certified by the the state
legislators
and that was done that was the that was
the the
the straw that broke the camel's back
there wasn't going to be any court case
there wasn't going to be anything that
was going to change it
that's why we had the violent
insurrection on january 6 because it was
a
it was it was white grievance lashing
out
um and these people were so easily
bought into a lie
and and i think that's what we're going
to call it in history is the big lie
that's what everyone's going to know it
as it's the big lie
so i think uh i think
that big lie after december 14th because
it was over there was no [ __ ] chance
he was ever going to win
it wasn't going to happen there wasn't
any kind of
constitutional thing there wasn't any
kind of legal thing there was nothing
that was going to change what had
already happened
we were just had to go through those
motions and mitch mcconnell even said it
after the 14th i mean the majority
leader
the republican majority leader of the
senate came out on the floor and
basically said
hey it's done there's nothing you can do
joe biden is the president-elect
you've exhausted all your legal any kind
of legal
thing that you would have in a court
the electoral college is done you can't
do anything about that it's certified
so i believe from that point is when
it really showed the worst of the worst
of us because there were some
republicans that
even voted for trump that
were were like okay it's over enough's
enough
enough of the lying enough of the
[ __ ] we don't need to pretend
like you won just to satisfy your ego
and make you feel better but it was the
worst of the worst of us and and i think
pointing that out and showing the entire
country that hey
there really is a big thing here that
has to be
dealt with it's it's called fascism
and it's in the form of white grievance
and unfortunately
for a lot of people i think a lot and
what i'm saying is a lot of people that
that vote republican normally that
identify themselves as christian
and go to church they're like this is
[ __ ]
embarrassing i mean you had mentioned
that
after january 6 because your dad is a
minister
and not only is he a minister i mean
this guy's like
you know jesus brother
jesus's brother and he's a conservative
he
he he he's a republican and and his the
one word that you said
was that he was thinking was
embarrassment
it was very embarrassing like a whole
chunk of my family
is republican and they were
embarrassed by january 6th
and it is it's really embarrassing it's
a whole bunch of republicans i feel like
they just really threw a temper tantrum
i think
isn't that what you said your dad says
like a baby fit kind of thing
it was a temper tantrum just little
toddlers not getting their way
right and unfortunately unfortunately uh
for the rest of us
we had to stand back and watch this and
and almost be branded by the rest of the
world
you know it's not just a it's not just a
stain to us it's a stain around the
world which
but the nice part is the nice part is
is that it was pointed out it was
pointed out
and now we know that this thing exists
inside of our country now we also know
we also know that the majority of us are
not going to put up with this crap
there's 81 million people that voted for
joe biden i believe there's probably
uh in the tens of millions of people who
voted for trump who are not for this
crap
like you're saying republicans who are
embarrassed they
they know joe biden one quit throwing
your [ __ ] ticket champion
sit down you lost that's enough we're
gonna move the [ __ ] on just like we
moved on
when when donald trump beat hillary
clinton we're gonna move the hell on and
we're gonna get on with this
so i think i think the numbers are
against them so and we'll talk a little
more about that today
so i want to get to some more topics so
thank you sam for joining me i know
you're going to have uh
your boys are going to be coming soon so
i'll cut you off you can
stay on here and okay and monitor some
of the comments
and uh we'll move on thank you for
joining us
we'll see you next week we'll see you
next week
all right so let's let's talk about a
few more
subjects here um i definitely want to
get into
these everyone should thank sam for
being on here and
having some conversations but i want to
get to this clip
um because this clip talks about january
6. i i did this
video the day after christmas and it
says right in the video that it's the
day after christmas
so uh but i wanted to play it
and i maybe should have played it last
week but i really didn't have a ton of
time
and i know this week i've told you guys
that i'm not going to stick to the
30-minute rule this week because we have
so much to talk about i do have a lot to
get to
but i do want to play this clip and talk
about several things
that went on from december 14th like i
was talking earlier up to january 6th
and then the events of january 6 how it
came to this point
and how america succeeded
we [ __ ] slam dunk this this [ __ ]
big lie white grievance nonsense this
white supremacy nazi [ __ ]
so let me play this
well merry day after christmas let's
talk paul poopypants is having a twitter
tantrum this morning calling on the
proud boys to come save him
i told you what this [ __ ] was up
to so wipe that cheeto ball dust off
your chin you
chewing on proud boy fake ass patriot
nazi [ __ ]
you got work to do on january 6th proud
boys why do these in-cell honey badger
[ __ ] call themselves the part
about it is the orange deity is calling
for a purge of mitch mcconnell from the
gop
it's maybe something we can agree on
here's the big [ __ ] secret
this is the way this clown show was
always gonna end
even lindsay they've got blackmail on me
graham saw it coming back in 2016.
also don't be surprised that on january
6 these pro boy q anon [ __ ]
we'll put pence in that deep state
category you know it's all part of the
cheeto chess plan
so sit back and enjoy the entertainment
because everything that trump touches
turns to liquid [ __ ]
[ __ ] him so
i guess the only words i can come up
with is i told you so
i mean to look back
and to see that video and to see that
this was going to end very badly very
very badly i never dreamed i never
dreamed the exact way this was gonna end
like that
but i was pretty spot on what do you
guys think
uh i wasn't far off from from what
happened
and they did they dunked pence
into this uh category of the deep state
uh pence today the imagery of trump
getting on the plane and having fanfare
and uh absolutely uh
uh you know blowing his speech
by saying oh we'll be back in washington
in some form
no you won't shut the actual [ __ ] up
you're not coming back and if you're
coming back it'll be in a pair of
handcuffs you dumb
[ __ ] so but the imagery
of pence not being there to wave bye-bye
to trump
and to tell him you know good luck buddy
and him showing up
to uh biden's inauguration and amy
klobuchar
one of the first people she acknowledges
is that vice president pence is right
here
when amy klobuchar does some of her
opening remarks
uh and even roy blunt acknowledging
uh that mike pence was there it was
almost an acknowledgement that
hey look who's not here look who's not
here
and for him not to participate in the
peaceful transfer of power
purposely not participate in that holy
[ __ ] i don't think that this senate
trial of his impeachment is going to go
very well on this
i think a lot of people see it as he is
a petulant child
and he lashes out intentionally and his
intention on january 6 was to incite
a riot just like i said in the video he
was calling on them
please come save me come january 6
help me get our country don't let them
take this away from us you know he was
saying this [ __ ] on twitter and
perpetuating and perpetuating and
perpetuating it
on and on and on he went about january
6th and how it was
you know come join us come join us come
to dc on january 6th
and then when they all get there and he
stokes them to walk up to the capitol
and don't take our government
and and we have to we have to save the
country
as if it was you know someone taking
something from them
and they did what they did and we know
what they did and it was it was [ __ ]
embarrassing it's still
embarrassing it'll be a stain on us
people are not going to forget january 6
and and all all the good stuff that
donald trump may have done or anyone
thinks that that he may have done
it will be absolutely overshadowed by
the events on january 6 and
i thought i thought for a long time
coronavirus was going to be his legacy
but i think even the [ __ ] and [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] up with the coronavirus would
take a
back seat to january 6th the way that he
tried to incite these people to have a
coup
so i think that's
that's part of his legacy unfortunately
so let's go to uh to these january
sixers
also because i want to talk about this
because apparently they are [ __ ]
pissed off
this morning on parlor because you know
you guys know that parlor's back right
it's uh not back on the app store but
it's back online and boy are they
[ __ ] typing away
typing away uh they're back at it
they're back spreading their [ __ ]
uh and believing that the q anon lies i
i i would love to be a fly on the wall
on some of these places and some of
these people's uh mother's basements as
they're typing on parlor today to
watch joe biden actually get inaugurated
but i digress on that uh so parlor's
back
and they're pissed off this morning that
trump did not pardon any of the
insurrectionist
which is [ __ ] hilarious that anyone
thought that donald trump gave two
shits about the people who stormed the
capitol
for him that he was going to that that
that he was gonna pardon them what the
actual [ __ ] are you
talking about no he was never going to
party he doesn't like you
he's never liked you he's never thought
you were cool
he never thought you were uh uh people
that he wanted to have
come on give me a [ __ ] break that's
not a thing that's not
a thing so
they're mad though because he they feel
like he turned on them
well when you believe a lie and you
perpetuate a lie and then you go act on
that lie
you might you might you might get your
[ __ ] feelings hurt
you might get some reality dumped on you
which i'm gonna have to do some more i
told you so
because i did i've done a ton of videos
on this on these january sixers and what
was going to happen to them
and how this was going to happen to you
i mean the the imagery
of jenna ryan i believe her name is this
realtor from
texas flying her private [ __ ]
jet to washington dc
storming the capital and live streaming
her federal [ __ ] felonies that she's
committing
then flying back to texas in her private
jet
all happy and and giddy about what she
just did
and when she lands this [ __ ] private
jet
she she figures out that this was not
probably a good thing that she did this
was probably
not a this was probably not a good thing
that she did was
was was live stream her felonies
so she
she puts on facebook how i don't condone
violence and i don't condone
vanillism and you know she tries to
really make up for what she just did
because she thinks oh it's a pr problem
this is just a pr
problem no biggie no biggie it's a pr
problem the president told us to do it
that's how these people viewed it [ __ ]
you seen the video on
cnn these guys were rummaging through
senator's desk
that possibly could have classified
information in it
and they're going oh yeah ted cruz well
he won't care he's on our side
ted cruz wants us to do this so no big
deal we won't be in [ __ ] trouble
the president told us to do it i mean
there's videos
of these these knuckleheads yelling and
screaming at law enforcement officers
that are trying to keep them
out of this building on that that
they're there unlawfully
and they're committing felonies going on
beyond secure areas
and they're saying our bot your boss
sent us
trump your boss sent us here get out of
our [ __ ] way
we have the right to be here we have the
right to do whatever it was that they
were gonna do
right so then
jenna ryan gets out in front of a camera
and whines and cries about oh
the president needs to pardon me i was
just trying to be a
patriot and not just one interview and
on her front porch she gave another
sit-down interview which was even more
embarrassing because she said i don't
feel
guilty but i want to pardon well
jenna ryan that's what a [ __ ] pardon
is is admitting your guilt you
dumb [ __ ]
knuckleheads [ __ ] boneheads and now
they're mad
now they're mad that trump didn't pardon
them which i'm not surprised
i think it's i think it's par for the
course of course he doesn't like you
there there was a moment there was a
moment for these people
in pop culture that could have told them
the truth about this [ __ ]
if they wanted to see it and i remember
it i remember it well because i live in
missouri and everyone here is chiefs
fans
and the chiefs won the super bowl last
year they won that [ __ ]
and everyone was excited that the chiefs
won because it's been a long
[ __ ] time since they've been to
a goddamn super bowl
and patrick mahomes was a great
quarterback
well still is a great quarterback we'll
see what happens this weekend because
the last weekend is injury but he's a
great quarterback
and it was a great super bowl it was a
great win
and this [ __ ] tweets out
about the state of kansas which everyone
who lives
near and is a fan of the kansas city
chiefs
realizes that kansas city chiefs
are not in kansas they're in
[ __ ] missouri and this should have
been a clue for everyone
that he does not and it wasn't like he
just had a boneheaded moment where oh
they're called the kansas city chiefs
so it must be from kansas and he flubbed
and you know missed a couple keys on the
keyboard when he was tweeting
no that is not what happened what
happened is
donald trump would never ever ever
ever buy or build a hotel
anywhere near kansas or missouri would
not [ __ ] do it
especially kansas city he sees this
place missouri kansas the midwest
as gross it's gross and it's not it's
not good enough
he wouldn't [ __ ] even hardly fly to
kansas city
let alone build a hotel there are no
anywhere anything about kansas city
or the surrounding areas he wouldn't he
didn't give two [ __ ] shits
that's why he tweeted that because he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't care he doesn't give a [ __ ]
and that should have been a [ __ ] clue
to a lot of people
that like oh well maybe he is just a
[ __ ]
maybe he doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about what i think he just wants
he just wants to say what i want to hear
so that should have been a clue it could
have been a clue
maybe maybe not
which uh leads me to the next thing
about pardons
since we're talking about pardoning the
insurrectionist
um one of the biggest highlighted uh
pardons that he actually did last night
was of mr
steve bannon steve bannon was the guy
who ran his campaign he was on his staff
for that first year as you know they
broke up
they had a real falling out after that
first year
so much so that he tweeted a couple
times and called him
sloppy steve he gave him the nickname
sloppy steve which i mean it's not
really that far
off i mean if you want to have a
nickname for steve bannon if you've ever
seen a picture of this guy jesus christ
slob sloppy you know it's not that's
that's
pretty good description of this
knucklehead
but he he pardons steve bannon
um which is kind of confusing uh
if you think about it so
donald trump promised to build a wall
and mexico would pay for it so he
he kind of builds a wall part of it fell
over with a stiff wind
and mexico did not pay for it which
is why steve bannon created a group
to raise money from trump supporters
people who voted for trump
to raise money to build their own wall
and then what he would they would build
their own wall
and then steve bannon stole the money he
took the money from the trump supporters
so trump promised to build a wall he
promised mexico would pay for it mexico
did not pay for it
he had steve bannon go raise money to
build a wall
steve bannon stole the money from his
supporters from his voters
trump's staunchest supporters gave steve
bannon money and he stole it from them
along with three other guys three other
guys are his co-defendant on this case
but steve bannon steals the money from
them and then
trump pardons him from stealing the
money fleecing the money from his
supporters
what and how you couldn't even [ __ ]
make this [ __ ] up
i mean in in a episode of the west wing
or house of cards this couldn't even be
made up
buddy pardon steve bannon and i guess um
he was off and on you know hot and cold
on this
he wanted to pardon him he didn't want
to pardon him he wanted to pardon him he
didn't want to pardon him
and i'm sure it has a lot to do with the
fifth amendment the reason why it has a
lot to do with the fifth amendment
because if trump ever has anything to do
with this case
uh about the wall and the raising of the
money if there's any whiff of trump
having anything to do with it
steve bannon cannot actually plead the
fifth
because he can't self-incriminate
himself in this case anymore which is
really bad for his co-defendants
because his co-defendants didn't get
pardoned i don't think
i didn't see where they got pardoned and
in that case
if the judge and the prosecutor want to
push the issue of steve bannon
talking he he can't self-incriminate so
it really
[ __ ] with these other three guys on
this case which
you know [ __ ] them [ __ ] them don't give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] them they stole that they
stole those people money
[ __ ] them and those people should be
infuriated
that not only did they get their money
stolen from them but now the president
pardons the guy that stole their [ __ ]
money
we we gave money and supported you of a
wall that you wanted that you couldn't
get mexico to pay for
and we gave it to the guy that you
wanted us to give it to
and then he steals it from us and you
[ __ ] pardon him what the [ __ ]
you kidding me this is this is the thing
that we're gonna do
but you know so so the other there's a
few other pardons there was a
a former detroit mayor
there is uh uh brody which is part of
trump's inauguration committee where
they were laundering money
um through that a lot of this is is
trump cronies that were on this list and
the
the other the other thing that was on
this list uh was a lot of
crooked politicians i mean you there was
a lot of racketeering charges
that he pardoned a lot of money
laundering uh
a lot of bribery charges that he was
pardoning you know
i don't know if he's projecting or not
but if he is he's [ __ ]
uh the other thing that he did last
night after his pardons is he lifted the
ban on lobbyist
so you guys remember when he first
became president they had this
we're going to drain the swamp you mean
they've been saying this [ __ ] we're
going to drain the swamp
and one of their issues to drain the
swamp was to
uh put a ban on lobbyists actually
getting back into lobbying after they
had worked for the administration
uh but he lifted that ban last night so
i guess it was just like a
a major major look kind of executive
order
like yeah we thought we would do that
but now we rescinded at the last moment
so
you can go do whatever you want uh so he
rescinded that order which is
a whole another ball of wax
and uh what to say see what else
happened the other thing the other
pardon that i didn't see
and this is the pardon that i really
wanted like i wanted this pardon more
than
any other uh even more than donald trump
to pardon himself which i do want and
i'll explain that here in a minute
but this pardon is the pardon that i
wanted the most of
all i wanted him to pardon joe exotic
and it's not because i think joe exotic
is not guilty or
that he should be pardoned i just
selfishly want
a season two of tiger king i mean
is is that is that's [ __ ] selfish of
me that i want a season two of tiger
king that
i think trump should apply if there was
one that i could pick
like please like if i could lobby trump
say all right man
i know you got a list of 500 names that
you
that you're gonna wanna pardon but why
not
why not give your fellow reality tv show
[ __ ] bag a [ __ ] pardon i mean think
about it you could even maybe produce
the show
right come on you're a great reality tv
show we've had reality tv president for
the last four years
this would be perfect why he didn't part
him i don't know so i'm kind of
disappointed that he didn't
pardon joe exotic but it's kind of a
selfish reason because i
i just i just want season two of tiger
king
i just i just want season two but let's
get to the pardons of him and his family
now
we don't actually know a lot of people
have pointed this out that he can
actually pardon people in secret
in other words he can pardon them do the
paperwork they can accept the pardon and
it doesn't have to be announced publicly
on any kind of memo or press or anything
like that the only time we would know
that something like that would happen is
if they were indicted
so if he was to pardon don jr per se or
eric or
ivanka or jared or whoever he would
pardon that was in his family or even
himself
then uh he could keep those pardons
secret
uh up until the moment that they have to
defend themselves in court against
indictment
where they would have pardoned
themselves from that crime
uh so now i definitely
i really wanted trump to pardon himself
and here's why
i think that that needs to be challenged
um
this pardon power obviously in the last
few days because of the stress
of who he was going to pardon how he's
going to pardon watching him pardon
people that he was kind of
co-conspirators with
is kind of [ __ ] gross and i i just
i just want to know i want to know and i
think the country needs to know
for the sake of having the reigns on
that power
is can the president knowingly and any
president not just trump but any
president anyone who becomes president
can they knowingly commit federal crimes
whether it be bribery extortion
moneyline whatever it may be
whatever those federal crimes may be can
they knowingly commit those federal
crimes
knowing that they can just write a a
secret pardon
in the very last moment of their
presidency and
they'll be fine they know that they'll
be fine we need to know that
and the reason why we need to know that
is because if that's the truth
if that's how it actually is if if a
president any president i don't care if
they're [ __ ] democrat
republican independent man woman black
why i don't care
if we need to know if a
president can pardon themselves from
doing something while they're president
i actually think that the constitution
allows them to pardon themselves
from something that they did before they
were president unfortunately and i think
that needs to be changed
um it definitely needs to be changed
because the only thing in the pardon
language
that isn't an indication that it's an
all-encompassing power
is the power is the power to pardon an
impeachment
now a lot of people i think have been
confusing this
because i've heard a lot of people say
oh well you they
can't pardon these insurrectionists
because he was impeached for that
insurrection
well i don't believe that's what it says
i don't think that's what the
constitution says
the constitution says that he can't
pardon himself from
an impeachment so if he's impeached he
can't say well i'm impeached but i have
the pardon power so i am par
i pardon myself from impeachment because
an impeachment is an
indictment it's a federal indictment
it's a federal indictment from congress
to the president and any any he can
pardon any federal indictment but his
own impeachment
so he can't he can't [ __ ] with that
power
congress's power to impeach trump's his
pardon power now rather that extends to
other people
inside of that legal realm
or rather it protects um
the impeachment in a criminal court on a
different indictment i don't think
that's the case
i don't think that um that he
can't pardon himself from
or that by by being impeached for
insurrection
and citing an insurrection i don't think
even if he pardoned himself from that
i don't think that he can be federally
charged
in a criminal court i absolutely think
he can and i don't think that he's bound
to pardon people that are involved in
that insurrection i don't think that was
the case now maybe that was his logic by
not
by not pardoning these people but i
think it goes to a much more shout level
of
he didn't like these people he really
didn't like his supporters i mean there
were stories that
he was watching the tv when they were
storming the capitol he was disgusted by
him
i mean mainly because the guy with the
[ __ ] horns and the face paint
and these guys walking around in their
[ __ ] their half-ass army costumes
uh he he thought they were they're
yokels so
um so so those pardons happened last
night
and i know i know we're going to learn
more about um
what these pardons are who was pardoned
over the coming days and uh
it probably won't even really amount to
much unless he did secretly pardon
himself and their families
um and there's going to be a lot of
stories i'm sure on on the money that
was exchanged
uh because that was some big stories
about how these attorneys were
and people close to him were being paid
to lobby they're being paid to lobby
these
these pardons so if i'm close to the
president i can
say yeah joe schmoe you want a pardon
pay me 50 grand i'll put a i'll put a
little nugget in his ear
apparently that is not illegal um to
to sell your influence to the president
now i believe it is illegal for him to
take payments and
we'll find that out now that's that
brings up another good point about these
pardons and him pardoning himself and
his family
and even pardoning steve bannon and some
of these other
corrupt politicians and uh these [ __ ]
criminals
if anyone believes that steve bannon
because he received a pardon as of today
when
when donald trump's no longer the
president to protect him with a pardon
if anyone believes that steve bannon is
just gonna stop committing federal
crimes
if you believe that holy [ __ ]
i i've i've got a story about election
fraud that i'd like to sell you
because if anyone thinks that that
donald trump
don jr eric ivanka trump
jared kushner steve bannon some of these
other knuckleheads like roger stone paul
manafort if if people think
that these people are just gonna just go
cold turkey and not commit federal
crimes
anymore you are a [ __ ] bonehead
these people are certainly gonna commit
future
crimes and even if they can and and he
did pardon them
from crimes that they committed before
he left
office he will not be able to pardon
them
for crimes afterwards and this idea that
these people are just going to go cold
turkey and never commit crime federal
crimes ever again is
kind of [ __ ] boneheaded so i believe
we're going to have more and more
stories about this and we're going to
talk about it on here so stay tuned
to the trump legal problem because
that's what it's going to be
that's what it's going to be so what
else did we miss and then i'll i'll
finally finish my thoughts on the
inauguration
uh we missed some things last week on um
on this insurrection
with uh bobert miss lauren i think her
name's lauren bobert of colorado
uh there's a lot of stories going around
that she was actually giving
tours of the capitol there was some
there was some noise about that
uh early last week that she was giving
tours or someone
someone was giving tours and then uh
it was out of that she was actually
giving tours now
she says she was not giving tours
because there was no official tours in
the capitol at the time
because the capitol was closed to tours
because of the coronavirus
but that does not mean she was not
leading people around in a in a personal
entourage around the capital um so i
think we're going to find out more about
this
and the reason why this all came up in
speculation is because there was a video
that was circulating
that what seemed like it could be beau
bert's mother i don't think it is
in the video um i've watched the i've
seen the uh video clip i've seen the
pictures
the official fbi pictures and it it
looks similar to her mom but it doesn't
to me it doesn't look like her mom uh it
doesn't look like it to me
but her mom was confirmed to be in
washington that day so
it raised a lot of eyebrows but the
thing that rose the most eyebrows in the
story
is when her communication directors up
and quit after two weeks
and that would indicate that someone got
to the communication director and
decide and she decided it would probably
be a good legal decision not to be on
her team anymore
because they did release several
statements they they they
and it is possible if there wasn't a
various stuff here
uh you know if what they're alleging is
true is that she was giving
reconnaissance
uh tours and to these insurrectionists
and what seems like could be white
supremacist groups because
man she's taken a lot of pictures with a
lot of people throwing up the you know
the
the white power the three percent sign
um
you know some some shady characters
that would possibly be linked to
extremist groups um that came to the
capitol
and if she was shown to give people like
that
reconnaissance tours like they're
alleging that could spell trouble for
miss bobert i think she should resign
she was tweeting nancy pelosi's location
and that's enough
for them to expel her on the floor of
the house i believe
along with marjorie marjorie taylor
green um this this
cuckoo bird she's a cuban honor same way
as boober
and uh it just it just complete nonsense
that these people believe but i i
believe this is a good thing for the
republicans they really need to work
this out to their party they need to
figure out
are we gonna let this nonsense live
inside of our party and be elected
officials are we gonna
you know cast these people out and they
can they can essentially
they can essentially tamp these people
down uh kevin mccarthy
as long as he's the minority leader he
does not have to give them committee
assignments
and if a congress person does not have
committee assignments
they are [ __ ] worthless um i'll give
you
a recent example of this that happened
inside the republican party his name was
steve king from iowa
uh steve king from iowa is a [ __ ]
racist
uh and he doesn't he doesn't he didn't
hide it he doesn't care
he's gonna say he's racist he's gonna
show his races he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he still doesn't give a [ __ ] even though
he lost and
uh the republicans known he's racist
forever because he's a [ __ ] outright
racist it just kind of started to bite
him in the ass it really started
to affect them and leadership so that's
when they decided to do something about
it you know
this is this is the demo of these
[ __ ] is you know
we'll let them be racist and it's okay
until we have to do something
so you remember they took him off all
his committees
and then steve king lost to another guy
that was just as trumpy as him and
probably just as racist as him
it just steve king couldn't do anything
why would you send a member of congress
if for your district vote for them if
they they actually
can't do anything like they can't
present any bills into committees or
anything they can't do anything they're
worthless
they're they're just a [ __ ] suit
sitting inside of an office
i mean steve king didn't even most of
his staff quit
uh because he didn't need staff what do
you need staff for if you can't do
anything
so uh i i think i think if the
republicans
had any honor here which they've shown
that they still don't over this last
week
because of these this [ __ ] about
unity that they've been talking about
you know don't blame us we want unity
don't blame us please please don't hold
us to account because we want unity
you said you want unity don't hold us to
account well someone needs to be held
[ __ ] accountable for what happened on
january 6th
and if there are members of the congress
and members of the senate who had
anything to do with it and i'm talking
to you ted cruz and josh hawley too
and by god they need to be held
accountable
so we'll see what happens with that and
we need to keep calling for these people
to be expelled
for what happened on january 6th the
next thing that happened though
this week since i missed it was the my
pillow guy
the mypelo nazi how [ __ ] fantastic is
this this guy
this guy just [ __ ] can't stop falling
on his goddamn face he's
he's there january 6 he's he's yelling
and screaming
and talking about uh talking about
[ __ ] on january 6th and how they're
gonna
keep the country and all this nonsense
and then uh he shows up at the white
house
to talk to the president to you know do
another coup
to do a uh a pillow coup i did a video
about it i did a tick talk about it
and um you know this guy loses
a bunch of his retail outlets he gets on
any [ __ ] about how he's losing
his business and it's bad for his bit
well then shut your [ __ ] mouth and
dummy you have the freedom of speech in
this country you certainly have that
but you also have the right to [ __ ]
remain silent
you have the right to remain silent so
maybe you should think about exercising
that right you've
bonehead okay so let's get to the
inauguration because there was a lot of
stuff
a lot of stories leading up to the
inauguration and a lot of people
you know we're on edge i mean this thing
was kind of tense i mean there's
fences and uh razor wire i mean
some of the images that were coming
around the white house and around the
capitol i mean it looked like a prison
uh an armed national guard standing all
the pictures we had from the capital of
uh uh dozens and dozens of national
guardsmen and women
laying on the floors trying to sleep on
the on the on the marble floors
it's weird it's weird imagery
it is weird we don't see that kind of
imagery
and it's it's all because of what
happened on january 6 and that they
perpetuated this stuff
so they they had to have extra secure
measures and and the one story that
that that kind of rose people's eyebrows
is they expelled
uh not expelled but they they they
relieved
12 guardsmen from their duty um at first
it was
two they had reported that they that the
fbi and secret service had done
background checks on all 25 000 troops
or what was near 25 000 troops
in washington dc for the inauguration
two of them
were shown to have ties or
what seemed like ties to extremist
beliefs or extremist groups
and then they said the number was 12.
with a little more investigating i found
out that
that not all 12 were directly tied
to extremist groups this was more about
uh things that they had said so it seems
like they they told these
these troops these guardsmen and women
that when you come to dc there is going
to be a zero
zero tolerance rule for
[Music]
having any kind and showing any kind of
willingness
to to either have shenanigans
or stop the inauguration or
you know the worst of the worst which
would be to act
uh in an act of war death uh
and and there was zero tolerance for any
of that and what it seems like
is the majority of those 12 were
actually
relieved of their duty because of that
zero tolerance rule
now rather someone was saying something
that was serious or joking we will
probably never know this
and the reason why we will probably
never know this is because it is
it is the military it is the secret
service um
and and it is the fbi so uh they're
probably going to keep that
a secret at least as long as joe biden
is president i'm sure we really won't
hear
exactly why those people relieved of
their duty
but it did it did uh it did certainly
put people on edge and man it's really
it's a
it's something we should really think
about and and um joe biden's
secretary of defense that uh they're
they're going to be confirming soon the
senate will be confirming soon
is uh his statement on it was that they
need to
to go through the entire military which
i think
i think i think we've been long overdue
to do
psych value evaluations of
not just the military but anyone who
takes an oath
to the constitution and and to the to
law
and order whether it be police officers
fbi agents
military national guardsmen
anyone who would take an oath really we
need to
really uncross these wires as it were in
this country
that that somehow somehow someone's
trying to take something away from
someone else
and and that's and that's this this
white privilege
uh you know i i've been talking about it
for several weeks
i said it on last week's podcast uh and
i said it in a video this week
that equality
to some of the privilege feels like
oppression
and the fact that that that white people
in this country
feel like equality when equality is
given to other groups of people that
they actually lose something that's all
[ __ ]
that's that's that's all [ __ ] and
it's all gemmed up
uh by by these white supremacist groups
by these white grievance groups and and
honestly the unfortunate part is
it's leaked into american christianity
and it has been for
the last 20 or 30 years and you know
there's always been movements that have
tried to
subtly do this uh when barack obama was
elected
they came out with the tea party you
know they taxed enough already they
they acted like it was tax and deficits
and they've been doing this since newt
gingrich
and newt gingrich is kind of the father
of this of this
white grievance movement uh to try to
you know uh subtly rewire
white america to where hey they're
stealing your country again
and and slowly but surely they work
their way to trump
and trump does not keep the quiet part
quiet he says the quiet part out loud so
white supremacists neo-nazis these
professional
professional white supremacists and
these people are professionals
these people make a living being white
supremacist
were able to they were not only
emboldened by trump
and emboldened by his language but they
were given
certain little things that were able to
re-wire american christianity and one of
those things is cuban on
uh i believe that q anon didn't start
as maybe a white supremacist uh lie and
and and reprogramming of america but i
believe that
that the professional white supremacists
in this country seen a lot of
similarities
in what they want to convince white
people of and how q anon was
reprogramming these people
and they said you know what there's no
there wasn't like an actual leader
there was never a person it was always
this this this
this figure of online someone was online
so they're really able to reprogram
white america
by by using this theory of q anon
and getting them to believe white
supremacist things
without people actually knowing that it
was neo-nazis and white supremacist
groups
and white nationalist groups that were
reprogramming their brains they were
hiding behind this this internet cloak
of
cuanon um and i still think we have this
reckoning to come
to uncross the wires of america
as it were and and and
get rid of some of this this q and stuff
that will never we'll never get rid of
conspiracy theories we'll never fully
get rid of fascism i mean these are
ideas
and that's that's what you get when you
have freedom
is you're gonna have some people that
have really [ __ ] bad ideas
because it's their freedom to have bad
ideas it's their freedom
bad ideas but that's where our unity
needs to come from
we need to unify uh uh together
to be against these horrible
horrible [ __ ] ideas and crush them
and the biggest one is fascism
and that's where a lot of this neo-nazi
white supremacy stuff is born and that's
where it bled into q anon
which q anon bled into american
christianity really well too
um and and that's that's really [ __ ]
unfortunate but
that's what has happened in this country
and i think that's that's going to be
the long road that we have ahead of us
because i said in my take one of my tick
tocks today i said
the last four years is fascisms
in this country white privilege white
grievance
last hurrah i think this was their last
hurrah
for a long time and and it's it
they they seen it coming they seen that
it was their last hurrah and that's why
they really hung on to it for a long
time
that's why they hung onto this hope that
somehow january 6 was going to turn
around
and then somehow today they were going
to cut joe biden and donald trump's
faces off and
transplant them and donald trump was
gonna continue being present looking
like joe biden have you heard this [ __ ]
this is a real this is a real thing so
it's i think it started out as a troll
online talked about um this face-off
theory what the actual [ __ ]
you guys have seen the movie with john
travolta and nicholas cage in it
um i don't remember what year is from
but it's surely from the 90s
but where they switch faces and in the
movie it's really
[ __ ] cheesy because they switch faces
but they don't switch bodies
and it and that they obviously are not
built the same
why they picked two actors that had two
different body types
i don't know but they did and it's the
movie's totally unbelievable
on its face no pun intended
but these people are spreading around
that
that donald trump is wearing joe biden's
face
somehow or joe biden's a hologram i've
heard this one too joe biden's a
hologram
this is the nonsense this is the
nonsense
this is like tr and it's like trying to
argue with people
who believe the movie star wars is real
imagine for a second trying to argue
with someone
trying to debate someone who really
truly believes that the star wars movies
are
[ __ ] real
be very very very [ __ ] difficult
so this all put the inauguration at risk
but they were safe today there was no
didn't seem like there was any incidents
uh i haven't seen any reported incidents
there was no storming the capital there
was no taking their country
back there was no they were gonna do
whatever it took at all costs
to stop biden and of course we seen over
the weekend there was no
there was no violence and no [ __ ] at
any of these state capital events
um that they were there and they had
their guns in a few states and they were
yelling and screaming into
bull horns and microphones and uh
exercising their freedom of speech and
exercising their second amendment right
which is all fine and good
as long as they don't step over the line
like they did on january 6 which
i think it was mainly mostly peaceful
so we should give them credit there they
they were peaceful and
they're still nazis but they were
peaceful nazis over the weekend so we
need to keep our eye on them but uh
it went out with uh without a bang and
joe biden's speech
uh was was a really good speech it did
talk about unity again
i i don't think i think joe biden's
pretty genuine in this
and even in my tick tocks i don't really
i don't really speak of joe biden like
he's some kind of great figure because i
i
you know i think joe biden is a decent
guy uh i
i definitely think joe biden knows how
government works i mean he's been in
government for a long
time and i don't think that's a bad
thing here i really think the good part
is is that he has been a government the
[ __ ] knows what he's doing
he knows how it works he knows the
levers he knows the buttons
he knows who to go to and when to go to
it and how to go to it
i mean he was the vice president for
eight goddamn years and it's not like he
was uh
second-hand vice president i mean
admittedly barack obama has said
that joe biden was his partner in the
presidency i mean they really
worked together and and and barack obama
leaned on joe biden for a lot of things
uh to get a lot of things done and
that's because joe biden was in the
senate for a long time
and this guy was no you know flack in
the senate he held
chairmanships in the senate so so i
think
i think joe biden uh will be a a decent
president now history is going
to be very kind to joe biden and the
reason why i think history is going to
be kind to joe biden is because he's
he he's he's right after trump
so he's always always always always
going to be compared to trump which is
always going to put him in the category
of a damn good president i mean anybody
anybody
compared to this [ __ ] especially
this legacy of january 6 because that's
going to be his legacy folks is he tried
to overthrow the constitution
he tried to commit a coup and he's going
to probably be found guilty in the
senate of it
if not in a federal court in a federal
criminal court
that's going to be his legacy that's it
he he even he even went over and above
and beyond the most disgusting part
of his presidency of coronavirus and not
giving a [ __ ]
and killing 400 000 americans let
letting us just
out out to dry on this coronavirus thing
not giving a [ __ ] not doing a god damn
thing you know he wants to take credit
for warp speed and he wants to take
credit for the vaccine
which fine fine fine you you
you you got the country behind getting a
backs this idea that the vaccine we
should have it we should have it as fast
as we possibly can
well what that's a easy [ __ ] idea
when you [ __ ] the mass thing up you
[ __ ] the social distancing thing up
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
spreading this virus all across rue
america
because you convinced people that this
thing was not this just the flu
so you really [ __ ] that up so so this
whole idea about
getting the vaccine so quickly is all
[ __ ] in the first place because
they've been working on vaccines for
coronaviruses
for for decades not specifically covid19
but viruses that are coronaviruses that
are covid
they just had to get this vaccine
changed for covet 19 specifically
so because they've been doing that work
and scientist
science has been doing that work
for this long time is the reason why we
had warp speed and it worked
but they have totally [ __ ] botched
this distribution so that's probably
another
another day in another podcast talking
about the distribution of the vaccine
and there's going to be plenty of things
to [ __ ] about here folks
and there's going to be plenty of things
to [ __ ] about with joe biden and the
democrats because now they got the full
reigns of government joe biden's the
president
nancy pelosi is the speaker of the house
and soon chuck schumer
will be the majority leader in the
senate if he's not as we speak
and they have the full reigns so it's
your turn now
so you guys better do what you need to
do
and fix some of this [ __ ]
now that's not to say that they can't
you know be stopped
because uh government is a compromise so
you're not going to get 100
what you want but at least the adults
are in the room and we're watching you
adults
we're watching you so be careful
so i think joe biden will be known as a
good president uh
i think the idea of of a first
woman vice president is [ __ ]
fantastic as me and sam talked about
earlier
uh i i think that's uh one thing that
joe biden has shown so far that he is
willing to
to put women in
the institutions of government and have
no qualms about it
we are going to have a lot of first
female
appointments that have already happened
that will be confirmed
and they will be the official
secretaries of
whatever and there's going to be a lot
of first in that and uh because
i think i think it is time because guys
have [ __ ] this up long enough
men have [ __ ] this up long enough so
we need to uh
we need to get the ladies to uh clean up
clean this up they know what the hell
they're doing they
they know how to govern women know how
to govern they actually know
it's it's like an instinct that they
have why we haven't let them do it is
[ __ ] beyond me we would be so much
further ahead and so much better shape
if we would have let women govern
because they have the instinct for it
uh we would be much better off so
i think that's going to be big stories
to come
but the main story today from the
inauguration
that i want to take away is the imagery
down on the mall if you guys looked
at some of the video instead of having
people down on the mall because of the
coronavirus and all the security issues
that they were having
they actually put 2 000 american flags
at one
section of the mall and
that imagery of having all those flags
down there
was fantastic and
when you had lady gaga which was a
fantastic performance of the
national anthem and then jennifer
lopez's
america the beautiful it was
great and to watch them sing to the flag
to turn to the flag and
sing it because i think that's the main
thing that we have to do here folks we
have to take back this
we have to take back the american flag
we gotta take it back
they've disgraced it long enough
long enough they've disgraced this
goddamn flag long enough
it's not theirs they're not patriots and
they they've talked about starting a
patriot party which
will be another podcast too i'm sure
but they've disgraced this flag long
enough it's america's flag she wants it
back and we
need to give it back to her and i think
today was a good start with that imagery
of having those flags on the mall in the
place of
people not being able to be there for
security reasons and for coronavirus
for the virus and the pandemic i think
it's super important
i think it's super important that we
take this flag back and i'm i'm proud
that now it you don't have to go out on
your porch and hang the flag and be
scared that someone's going to think
you're a [ __ ] trump supporter
and that that that was the most pathetic
part about it
is they bastardize our flag so
so a couple more things before i leave
the podcast and i appreciate you guys
tuning in today for episode 2 on
inauguration day
and you can tune in next week on
wednesday same time 3 o'clock central i
think we're going to have a guest next
week i don't want to give away who it is
but
uh this person has said they want to
come on i i haven't confirmed the time
for them to come on next week but it is
another tick tocker
so you people out there that like tick
tock uh you will know this person
uh and they do talk about politics on
tick tock so that's good i wanted to get
their perspective
on things um so so that that's important
that i i want to get a few other
perspectives i want to look through the
lens of other people on this podcast for
you guys to
hear more extended to their views than
just the sickest 60 seconds that podcast
gives
or a tick tock gives them so um
but i do want to thank you for your
support all your likes and follows
and all the duets you've been doing i do
want to ask you if you would support our
podcast you could go to the merch store
uh you can buy some stickers a coffee
cup all that money would go
towards the podcast here and producing
more episodes and doing that
so that would help us out a lot i'm
gonna go ahead i'm gonna go ahead and
play something real quick so you guys
can see
some of those products and i'll i'll
i'll see you on the other side
[Music]
all right so if you go to
thetonymichaels.com and and follow the
links to the merch store
you guys will be able to find some of
those products and if you use the promo
code podcast you'll get 10
off anything uh in there so there's
shirts there's some pillows you seen
there's some sweatpants some hoodies
uh coffee cups all kinds of good stuff
that says [ __ ] um
on it because you guys like that you
like that phrase so uh so
support us there that would be awesome
that would be great and again
come back and see us next week on
wednesday at three o'clock go follow me
on twitter
if you don't it's really easy it's also
on the tonymichaels.com you can follow
me on all the stuff there so go to the
the tony's michael the tonymichaels.com
and see all that good stuff
but i'll see you next week and uh before
i go
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them